everybody what is going on welcome to
part three of our matplotlib tutorial
series in this part we're gonna be
talking about is 3ds scatter plots so
with this code we can actually use quite
a bit of the previous code the only
thing we're gonna get rid of is plotting
for the wireframe so what we'll do is
we'll just lose comment this out for now
and the next thing that I want us to do
is we need some more variables so I'm
gonna well yeah I guess we'll just do X
let's copy this line at least copy paste
and in fact let's copy this whole thing
copy paste and then the X we'll just
make these all whoops make these all
negatives negative negative negative
negative negative just make all these
negatives so they're kind of like in
their own little place basically
negative negative negative negative
negative negative and negative and one
more negative okay good enough so with
scatter plots it's really quite simple
you can basically will use the first set
first and then we'll come on use the
second set last you can do something
like this X 1 dot scatter and then you
pass the X the Y the Z that's really all
you have to do so first we can bring
that one up and so now we've got these
scatters and another little cool thing I
mean you can you can kind of tell but
the plots that are like further away
from being the closest I guess the
closest ones are totally filled right
they have a solid alpha and the ones
that are further back have a lesser
alpha and so and then as you move it
that starts changing so it kind of gives
you a little more feeling of depth to
the to the charts and we can kind of do
the same thing that we've done before
with the zooms and all that to kind of
look at these plots and all of that kind
of stuff otherwise everything pretty
much remains the same so let's close out
to this and what we can do though is we
can scatter another bit here so like we
can do a X 1 dot scatter and then do X 2
y 2 Z 2
and on that and we can do that and we
can see there's kind of two bodies here
but we don't see any difference but what
we can do just like we can do with any
of the scatter plots we can change the
color so we could say C equals R and
then C equals K and then we can even we
can change some stuff so you can say
like marker so right now the marker is
an O like that so a comma marker oh but
you can like we were talking about
before you can make them whatever you
want so we can make them stars for all
that matters so now they're stars some
are black the others are red that was a
bad idea on my part my bad guys so let's
do blue and red something a little more
let's do green in red just something
that's obvious difference sorry for the
colorblind folks out there still can't
really see much of a difference here we
might want to make the marker size a
little bigger but the other thing we new
stars are just hard to see let's do like
Oh again and Oh try it one more time
there we go so those are easier to see
so we'll stick with us anyway so this is
kind of our way of being able to compare
three dimensions and maybe see the
difference between three dimensions of
data here so anyways those are three
dimensional scatter plots for you not
really too much more to it it's a lot
like a scatter plot only with another
dimension so that's it for this tutorial
if you have questions or comments please
feel free to leave them below otherwise
as oh it seems for watching thanks for
all the support and subscriptions and
until next tutorial